Last time we talked about a number of monuments that were connected to one
another geographically and also chronologically and we're also made out of the
same material concrete faced with opus and Keratin.
I remind you of three of those today of the sanctuary of Jupiter anchor at terra
cina of the sanctuary of Hercules,
victor at Tivoli in the center and then on the right,
the sanctuary of Fortuna Prima Jania at Palestrina.
We're going to do something entirely different today.
We're going to look at a single city,
one city in all its aspects.
It's public and private architecture.
It's civic,
commercial,
and religious buildings.
We can't do this sort of thing very often,
uh,
because too few Roman cities are either WellPreserved enough or well execute
well excavated enough to allow such an overview,
but this is no ordinary city.
This is a very special city.
The city we will be concentrating on today is Pompei.
Pompei was located in an area of Italy called Campania.
It was located near Naples.
It was located near the Mediterranean Sea.
It was a small resort town in the late first century BC and into the early and
into the first century,
a d.
And you can see it on this map here and it's,
it's uh,
it's right here.
Uh,
you can see that this area of campaign is obviously south of Rome.
It is a long,
again the Mediterranean Sea.
And you can see palm pay here also with its sister,
city of Herculaneum and some of the other well known cities from this area,
bus gory,
all lay a plant.
This for example at Naples itself,
ancient Neapolis.
Uh,
and you can see this cluster of these cities that make up Campania.
This was an area,
I mean this,
the town itself again was a small resort town.
It was a town that obviously had its own population of people who made their
money largely from commerce because they were located so close to the sea.
But it was also a spot that was highly favored by the Glitterati of Rome who
used to come down to this area of Rome,
not only to,
to go to palm pay itself,
but to establish bill is to build villas in the vicinity of palm pay.
And we have imperial villas at places like a plumpness and in a place called bus
go,
Trey Causey that is located here as well.
Uh,
and along what is now the Amalfi coast and on the island of Capri,
uh,
so this was a town again,
that was,
was noticed and was visited even by the most elite in the city of Rome,
in Rome itself,
and the city in the center and the capital city of Rome itself.
But what's very important for us from the outset is to recognize that although
Pompei as we know it today,
was essentially a Roman city,
it had a history that was much longer than that,
that went back much further than that.
And I'd like to go over some of the major highlights of the history of palm pay
because they will situate us and will help us to understand the city's
architecture.
The history of punk pay,
as I noted,
is much longer then the history of Roman palm pay.
It goes back as far as Rome itself.
It goes back to the eighth century BC,
the same iron age period when Romulus was founding,
the city of Rome Pompei goes back that far as well.
It was first overseen by an Italian tribe called the Oskins,
but the Oskins were soon taken over by an even more powerful tribe called the
Sam Nights.
And the some nights are in fact extremely important for the city of palm pay and
for the architecture that we'll review today,
the seven night period and Pompei lasted from the fourth through the third and
even into the second centuries BC,
uh,
up to 80 BC because it was in a 89 that pump pay fell to Rome.
We've talked about Rome colonizing,
uh,
this particular part of Italy,
not only the area right around it,
but the area south of it.
Uh,
and Pompei fell to Rome in an important military campaign in 89 BC.
And in 80 BC,
Sola made Pompei a Roman colony.
What happened thereafter was the Sam Knights who had built homes for themselves
in public buildings that will study here.
Uh,
the Sam nights were essentially,
uh,
thrown out of their homes.
Their property was confiscated,
and that property was given instead to the Roman veterans.
We've talked about the fact that that was the way the Romans operated.
They paid back their veterans for loyal service by giving them land,
and they usually gave them land of those that they had conquered.
So that happens here as well.
So I'm not property confiscated.
And the Roman veteran settle in their homes and begin to Redo them,
settle into using their public buildings,
but begin to remake them in the Roman image.
The next century and a half saw the construction of palm pays most famous
buildings.
But we should not forget,
and we'll concentrate in part on that today,
that some of these buildings had their genesis under the sem nights during this
period,
there was a very high civilization in palm pay.
Uh,
there was trade with Greek cities and especially with the Greek city of Naiop
opolous Neapolis being the ancient name for Naples or Naples.
The next very important year in the history of Pompei was the year a d 62 when
the city was literally the city of palm pay was literally shaken to its
foundations by a very significant earthquake,
a very significant earthquake.
Indeed.
And to give you some sense of that earthquake,
I show you,
uh,
a freeze that,
that in circles,
a shrine,
a that was located in the house or that was commissioned for the house,
uh,
as decoration and as a place to place the household gods that the owner and his
family worshipped.
The shrine had a freeze around.
The man himself,
by the way,
was named Lucius [inaudible] and we're very lucky to remember his name.
But Lucius [inaudible] you couldn't and you couldn't as,
uh,
fortunately we have a portrait preserved of you couldn't just so we can get a
good sense of what he looked like,
literally warts and all because you can see that he had a huge ward on the lower
left side of his face and he was willing to have himself a memorialize.
And here we are sitting and looking at him today and this classroom in new haven
as he really was with this large ward on the lower left side of his face.
Uh,
but a wonderful portrait of you couldn't as,
uh,
the owner of this particular house who was obviously so struck and probably so
affected in his own life by the earthquake,
uh,
that he decided to,
to have a relief commissioned that would depict the event,
uh,
of 60 to 80.
And you see exactly,
you see what is happening here.
You can see in fact the great temple of Jupiter,
the Capitol Liam upon pay,
which we'll talk about today,
literally a collapsing.
And you can see that in front of that temple were too tall basis with equestrian
statues honoring important people of the city.
Those look also like they are shaking in their boots so to speak and about to
fall over.
Uh,
if you look down here,
you see the city wall add note,
you're a Ashleigh masonry,
uh,
your opus quadro bottom and the use of headers and stretchers in this wall,
the wall of the city of palm pay.
But you can see the gate is not doing too well.
It is also,
uh,
seems to be tottering at about to fall down.
So,
uh,
this is a graphic depiction of what happened then and you can,
it gives you some sense of,
of the significance of this for the people of palm pay.
Now at the end of this,
like in so many natural disasters,
obviously these people love living where they did beautiful part of the world
and they essentially stood up and dusted themselves off and began to remake
their city to restore their city,
uh,
to what it was.
And we have a,
from this point on,
from 62,
on almost immediately 17 years of frenzied building activity in which palm
patients try to bring their city back from the dead,
so to speak.
Uh,
to bring it back to what it had once been.
But you know,
the punchline near,
you know,
the end of the story,
that all of this work,
all of this 17 years of hard work was all for not because on that fateful day of
August 24th,
uh,
in 79,
a d a the long dormant volcano of Vesuvius,
which you see looming up behind the temple of Jupiter in Pompei today,
uh,
the long dormant volcano of Vesuvius erupted covering the city of palm pay and
all of its sister cities in a mass of or in a blanket of,
uh,
of,
ash and lava covering it forever.
Well,
not quite forever,
almost forever because as you also know,
the city was rediscovered in the 18th century and when it was rediscovered a,
what happened there first was a period of a treasure hunting a well to do
individuals primarily from Europe,
uh,
made a beeline for Pompei once it was rediscovered and began to,
to build their own personal collections of art.
Uh,
from what lay around,
they took jewelry,
they took metal items,
precious metal items they even did,
did the unspeakable by cutting portrait paintings and other paintings out of the
walls and taking them back to decorate their own palaces and villas in other
parts of the world.
That went on for a while,
but fortunately not too long,
the archeologists gained the upper hand.
And we begin to see not long after that,
uh,
a period of scientific excavation.
And I show you two images here which show that scientific excavation,
which,
so some of the houses of pom pay being revealed by archeologists.
Uh,
and of course it was all the good work that they have done.
And work continues.
A pace at Pompei excavation still goes on in parts of the city that have allowed
most of the city as far as we can tell to be revealed to us,
to us today.
Now this tragedy that befell Pompei in in August of 79 was indeed a tragedy for
them,
for the people who live there.
Obviously it was also a tragedy for the reigning emperor,
a man by the name of Titus t I t u s who ha,
who was the,
uh,
honored and the famous arch of Titus in Rome.
We'll talk about him and his architecture and Rome later in the semester.
Uh,
but it was a disaster for him and he had to contend with a plague in a fire in
Rome also at the same time.
Uh,
it was very difficult for him and poor man,
even though he was quite young,
died of natural causes after only three years in office.
And I think it was in part this,
this,
this catastrophe that had happened in the Bay of Naples area.
Uh,
that led in part to his,
two of the stress of it led in part to his demise.
So this was a great tragedy for him,
a great tragedy for the people upon pay,
great tragedy for Rome.
But it,
it was a stroke of good luck for archaeologists and in a sense for us as well.
Uh,
because of course what happened to two palm pay is something very different than
what,
than what happened to Rome.
What happened to palm pay is that it was,
his life was snuffed out all at once.
It came to an end all at once.
Compare this to Rome,
which has been inhabited over millennia in Rome.
Buildings have been redone,
rethought,
remade,
uh,
over time that never happened in palm pay because palm pay again,
died essentially on,
in August of [inaudible] 79.
And everything that was there,
uh,
was preserved just as it was.
And that's how it was discovered when it was re,
when it was excavated in the mid 18th century as it had been exactly how,
how it has,
how it had been on that day in August in [inaudible] 79.
This is extremely important.
It's one of our only really fixed chronological dates and it provides us with an
incredible laboratory of material because again,
everything,
nothing is changed,
you know,
from the time that it was left there except for what the treasure hunters
removed.
But for the most part,
nothing has changed and we can study it as it was.
The other thing that you must remember from the outset that although what was
revealed by excavators,
uh,
in the 18th century,
19th century and beyond,
even today,
uh,
was not just the Po.
I mean it was the palm pay of eight of August 79,
but the buildings that stood there were not just the buildings that had been
renovated between the earthquake of 62 and the eruption of Vesuvius of 79,
but some of the very earliest buildings,
including the sem night structures,
uh,
still stood.
And so when we look back,
we will be able to trace in a sense,
uh,
the city of palm pay and it's architecture from this time of the stem nights up
until the time of the emperor Titus.
I want to begin with a plan of the city of palm pay and you see it here.
And the plan that I show you is a plan of the city as it was in a d 79.
We see all of the buildings at that juncture.
We see that the shape of the city is essentially an irregular rectangle.
Uh,
and we also can see very well that the city is surrounded by a wall,
a protective wall,
as were.
So it was walled like all the other cities that we've talked about thus far.
This term,
uh,
you can see some of the major buildings very clearly the amphitheater that we'll
talk about today,
the theater and the music hall.
Over here you can see the streets of the city,
the carto or north South Street and the deck you Montas or east,
West Street of the city,
as well as the fairly regular blocks where the houses and the shops were
located.
What is important to note,
however,
is that the Sam Knight's city was obviously much smaller than the city of 79.
And to recapture a sense of the Sab Knight City,
we have to look at the bottom left side of this plan where we see the original
Sam Knight City,
which seems to have been roughly a fairly regular square.
And in that Sam night city,
uh,
the Romans and they followed Roman surveying,
method methodology here.
Uh,
they,
they looked to what was exactly the center of the city and they placed the
Cardo,
uh,
the north South Street and the deck,
you Maness the east West street at that exact midpoint of the city.
And then they located as they like to do the forum of the city,
the great meeting and marketplace right at the intersection of the carto and of
the deck,
your Montas.
And that is exactly where we see the forum that was begun in the Sam night
period right at the intersection of those two original streets.
Then over time,
obviously as they expanded the city,
the Carto,
the carto grew and the deck you Montas grew,
and it didn't end up exactly at the center of the larger city,
but it was at the center of the original city.
The left's begin in fact with the forum because the forum was begun itself
during the time of the Sam Nights.
You'll see from your monument list that I've given you a date of the second half
of the second century BC,
uh,
for the forum at palm pay.
And again,
that indicates to us because of the chronology of the city,
of the history of the city,
that it was begun in some night times.
Uh,
you see here on the screen a,
an excellent plan of the forum as it was.
And as it grew over time,
as buildings were added over time,
this plan is from the text,
one of your textbooks from Ward Perkins.
And I think it,
uh,
it deserves a,
you know,
careful study.
Uh,
were we,
let's describe it together today.
We see that the central part of the forum,
which was again the essentially the main meeting and marketplace of the forum is
a very low,
a long gated rectangle with the temple at capital a,
capital Liam at temple to Jupiter located on one of the short ends and you
should be immediately,
your mind's eye should go immediately to the,
uh,
the sanctuary designs that we saw last time.
Think for example of the sanctuary of Hercules victor at Tivoli,
uh,
where we saw that the temple was pushed up against one of the back walls and
that's case the long wall and dominated the space in front of it.
We see the same kind of scheme here where we see this rectangular space with the
temple pushed up.
In this case,
I'm one of the short walls pushed up against the back wall and then dominating
the space in front of it.
The forum itself is surrounded by Co Collin Columns,
a colonnade as you can see here.
And uh,
and it is open to the sky,
open to the sky,
then deployed around it all.
The other important buildings that needed to be in a forum,
the,
uh,
Korea or senate house over here,
the basilica or law court over here and another temple in this case,
the temple of Apollo.
And then a series of buildings that were added later on the right side,
a wonderful building of a woman that we're not going to be talking about this
semester called you Makia,
uh,
who,
and it gives you some sense that women could wield power.
Uh,
it wasn't easy,
they couldn't vote,
they couldn't hold public office,
but they could sometimes wield power.
And this particular woman did in palm pay,
a very large building that was for her and for her trade guilt,
uh,
a lararium or a place,
a shrine,
a market or McCullum up there.
Some of these added later.
Uh,
and,
but the ones that are particularly critical to our understanding of the Sam
Knight City are the Capitol Liam and are the basilica which both date to the
second century BC.
Here's the view of,
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I did want to say something about the Google Earth image on the,
um,
on the left.
Uh,
this is a Google earth earth image,
which I tried to take in such a way that one could,
can see it almost exactly the same vantage point as the plan.
And you can see everything here that I've already pointed out.
The open rectangular space,
the colonnade,
the temple pushed up against the back wall of the temple of Jupiter.
The basilica over here,
the temple of Apollo,
you kias building here,
the,
uh,
Senate house over here and so on.
And this again underscores the value of Google Earth,
uh,
as one can can look down on these buildings and compare what one sees to the
master plan.
This is a view of the colonnade.
Uh,
it's a two story colonnade at the forum of Pompei.
And you can see the same thing that we saw happening in the theater,
Marcellus in Rome,
that the columns that they have used,
they have looked at the Greek,
the Greek orders,
the Doric,
ionic and Corinthian.
And they have selected here to use the Doric for the first story and the ionic
for the second story.
This colonnade does not date to the Sam night period.
We believe,
uh,
that it was put up later.
Uh,
but it,
it's made out of white limestone.
Uh,
and it probably again does belong to a,
uh,
a renovation of the forum of a somewhat later date.
Look also,
uh,
near the columns.
And you will see a series of basis,
a large base over here,
a smaller base over here.
You see a lot of these still in the forum today and what these bases were for.
Of course we're to support statues,
statues,
and then there would have been inscription on the base identifying who that was.
Sometimes they were statues of the reigning dynastic Rome age of Augustus that
might be Augustus or his wife Livia.
Uh,
but they also honored the,
uh,
the most important people of the city of palm pay,
magistrates great benefactors.
You Makia we know how to portrait inside her own building,
honoring her standing next to the Empress Livia.
Uh,
so that's,
you have to imagine that while the forum is quite empty today than an antiquity,
that would have been all of these bases with a question.
Ian Statues and full length statues vying with one another for attention.
The individual's honored their sort of jostling with one another to uh,
to underscore their,
their fame,
at least within their own city.
This is a view of the temple of Jupiter or the capital Liam in the forum of palm
pay,
an extremely important building.
Uh,
and one that you can see from the monument.
Lee's list also began what began to be put up quite early in 150 BC,
but it's triple Sela honoring the Capitol on Triad Jupiter,
Juno,
and Minerva was,
it won't surprise you to hear put up only after the Romans made Pompei a colony.
And that happened in ADBC.
So you'll see that I've given you a date of one 54 the temple,
but ADBC for the renovation of the Cella to incorporate these three spaces for a
statues of the Capitol on triad.
Let's look at the plan first.
You see it down here at the bottom.
Let me
move that Arrow way.
You see it down here at the bottom,
and you can see that the plan of the temple corresponds a to plans that we've
seen for other temples that we've studied thus far.
This term temple of [inaudible] for example,
where we see this combination of and a trust can plan and a Greek elevation.
You can see here the facade emphasis,
single staircase,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in that porch.
The flat back wall as was characteristic of a trust in temple design.
Uh,
the plane sidewalls over here.
we can see all of that in this plan.
Uh,
and we also know that the building was made out of Stone Tufa in this case,
Tufa not from Rome,
but too far from this part of Italy from the campaigning and region two for
their,
for the both the columns and also the capital.
So a stone building.
So this same combination of a trust can plan and Greek elevation that we saw in
Rome.
This view of the temple also shows you that it had a tall podium as was
characteristic of these other early temples.
Here you can see the remains of the stone columns a and of the building itself.
It's not as well preserved as we wish it were,
but enough is there to give us very good sense of what the capital Liam looked
like in ancient Roman times.
I mentioned that the other early structure added to the forum complex was the
basilica of palm pay and I'd like to turn to that now.
The basilica palm pay dates to around 120 BC.
You see its plan here again in the bottom left and you'll remember it's splayed
off from the forum to the left bottom side.
As you face the temple of Jupiter,
you can see that the plan of the basilica is very interesting because it
actually is quite similar to the plan of the forum itself.
It is a rectangular space,
not as large and not as elongated,
but nonetheless a rectangular space.
It's entranceway is over here from the forum.
You can see that there are columns inside a colonnade justice we saw in the form
itself and the building is org is,
is,
is organized as is the forum itself axially so that there is a focus,
something at the end that serves as the focus.
And then the axiology comes from that.
Uh,
we see the focus over here at the end.
It's not another temple.
It is a tribunal,
a tribunal on which the judge would sit to try the law cases that came here.
The main difference between the basilica and the forum itself is that the
basilica was roofed in antiquity.
The roof is no longer there as you saw on the Google Earth view,
but it was roofed in antiquity.
Whereas again,
the forum was open to the sky.
The view that you see of the basilica as it looks today is also very
illuminating.
We are looking toward the tribunal.
You can see the tribunal is actually extremely well preserved.
We get a very good sense of what it looked like in antiquity.
It itself has a tall podium.
We can imagine the Magistrate Holding Court,
uh,
up here on the top of that tall podium beneath between the Corinthian columns.
In this case,
we're not absolutely sure,
but we believe the second story,
which has smaller columns,
they diminish in size.
On the second story,
uh,
also were a Corinthian columns because you can see at least one of them,
one of them is restored at the top right,
but that one is a Corinthian capital.
So we believe Corinthian order on the lower story,
Corinthian order on the second story as well,
beginning to show this Roman pension for the Corinthian order,
which we've already discussed.
Uh,
and you can also see here a some of the,
the lower parts of the columns that would have been in circling the center of
the structure and dividing,
uh,
the central space from two aisles,
one on either side.
Uh,
it looks like they're made out of brick,
but they're actually made out of a tile that looks like brick.
A brick wasn't being used quite this early,
but a tile resembling brick was used in palm bay.
And we can see that served as the core of the columns.
They would've been stuccoed over though and looked more like white marble,
uh,
indicating to us again,
this desire of the Romans to make things look a at least or the Saturday nights
at this point.
And ultimately the Romans when they renovated this structure to make it look as
Greek as possible.
Yeah.
Why are the columns chopped off?
You mean almost all in the same,
same place?
You know,
these,
these things were often pieced and so sometimes they can,
that can happen.
And it's actually one of the new raise,
a very interesting issue,
uh,
because one of the things that,
that archeologists are beginning to speculate only recently about,
and you see this in some of the most recent literature is,
you know,
we think we here,
here we say,
and I said it today,
that this city was preserved exactly as it was in 79.
And yet when you look at what it looks like,
it's actually pretty,
pretty ruinous state.
Uh,
so that could mean two things.
One,
that they didn't make all that much progress.
And that's 17 years that they worked very hard,
but the damage had been so significant that they were not able to,
uh,
to bring these things back,
you know,
as much as they had hoped to.
But it also may be just the destruction.
I mean,
while while the ash and lava covered the city and protected it,
it obviously brought some damage as well so that some of these things,
you know,
obviously came down and over time the material got washed away or taken away or
whatever.
But it is curious that they sort of broke and exactly the same place,
but it's because because of the construction technique and the way in which they
were pieced together.
Yeah,
exactly.
Let me show you another view of the right side wall of the basilica.
You see these columns here again,
very regular.
There's a young woman standing right here,
so that gives you a sense of scale.
She's about only up to the,
this,
this point of the column.
So you can see how large and scale these all these were in ancient Roman times.
But if you look at the two that are closest to the tribunal,
you will see that they have ionic capitals.
So that gives us enough to go on to speculate that the first story of columns,
and there were two stories on the walls,
uh,
two stories of columns,
the lower ones where ionic and you can see that they are attached or engaged
into the walls.
Uh,
those were ionic.
And then we believe that there was a second story,
uh,
that we know there was a second story,
but that the SEC,
second story of columns,
uh,
would have been Corinthian capitals,
up there.
This is a restored view of what the basilica would have looked like,
uh,
in,
the,
in one 20 after it was built,
when 20 BC after it was built.
And you can see here the tribunal,
we're looking toward the tribunals.
It's two storied Corinthian order on both stories.
Tall podium.
We see here in black,
uh,
the,
um,
the columns of the central space that divide the center from the two side
aisles.
And here you can see very well the way in which they created two stories,
a bottom story and upper story.
You could,
you could walk on that upper story,
uh,
and using the ionic capitals in the first story and smaller Corinthian columns
in the second story,
and it's important for me to note in terms of the development,
the later development of Basilican architecture that this basilica in palm pay
of this early date did not have what's called a clear story.
C L E R e s t o r y c e R e.
A clear story.
What is a clear story?
A clear story is a series of windows open to the outside that allow views out
and light in this building does not have a clear story.
So it probably in its heyday in the stem night period was probably on the dark
side.
But we will see that clear story.
The clear story is incorporated into later Roman basilican architecture,
one of the greatest buildings without any question at palm pay and one that
everyone flocks to see.
And if you've never been to palm pay,
let me just note that it is a little bit further out than some of the other
structures,
but it is a to not be missed monument.
And in fact,
I know at least one of you is already spoken to me about an upcoming trip to
Rome and Pompei.
And um,
consequently I just say that you absolutely need,
I mean you could spend days at pom pay,
but you must have a full day,
full day for palm pay because in order to get to the,
and not just to see the forum and what's in the center and a few of the houses
to get out,
it doesn't take that lemon.
It's a nice walk.
It's not a big,
not a huge distance,
but,
uh,
people forget to do it because it's on the outskirts.
But you,
you really must get to the two end points are the amphitheater and the bill of
the mysteries,
both of them,
absolutely incredible to see him too often missed by tourists.
Uh,
but two of the greatest sites at the city of Palm Bay,
this is the amphitheater.
As it looks today from the air.
The amphitheater is one of several buildings that were begun immediately upon
the Romans Making Pompei a Roman colony in ADBC.
You can only imagine those veterans as army veterans of war who had just been
settled in their new homes clamoring,
uh,
from day one for the amphitheater,
a place where they could go for gladiatorial and animal combat.
This is what they wanted to see.
Uh,
and consequently,
no local magistrate or emperor worth their salt would allow the city to uh,
continue without,
uh,
there were no we've no emperor and ADBC,
but uh,
would,
would allow the um,
the city to be,
uh,
to,
to go on without an amphitheater.
So that was one of the first orders of business.
This amphitheater at palm pay,
which dates we believe to 80 to 70 BC is one is an incredibly important
building.
But the history of Roman architecture because it is our first preserved stone
amphitheater and all the empathy interviews that come later,
including the great Colosseum in Rome are based on buildings like this one.
This was a great experiment in amphitheater design already in 80 to 70 BC.
How do they go about building this amphitheater?
Uh,
what they seem to have done is to,
uh,
to excavate the central area of the earth of the central area to create a space
for the oval arena,
which you see here.
And I put the terms on,
the monument was for you,
the arena,
which you see here.
So they've excavated that central space,
place the arena there.
Then they have piled up earth.
It's essentially an earthen bowl is what they've created here.
And earthen bowl with the excavated space for the arena and then piled up the
earth on the outside to support the seats,
to support the seats,
to serve as a support for the seats.
There was no natural hill here,
so they had to do this on their own.
Uh,
so they build up the earth,
they place the seats,
they line that earthen bowl with seats,
stone seats,
uh,
and they create the cabiya of the amphitheater because we use the same term for
the seats of an amphitheater.
As for the seats of a theater,
the Kava,
or see a VA,
the Kavya or the seats of the amphitheater.
And you can also see here light in in indicated,
uh,
the wedge shaped sections of the seats,
just as in the theater.
They are called the same thing.
The KUNAE Scu and eus,
or in the plural Kunae,
I a.
So these wedge-shaped individual sections,
a Coonass,
all of them together.
Kunae he the KUNAE or wedge shape sections of the seeds apparent here,
the exits and entrances.
And there are a couple of major ones on either side.
Those have a colorful and unforgettable name.
I guarantee you,
you will remember this name for the rest of your lives.
Uh,
those exits and entrances are called vomitorium,
uh,
which means they literally spit forth spectators,
vomitorium,
uh,
these exits,
these entrances and exits to the amphitheater.
Let me also note that the outer ring and the outer ring is extremely important
because it buttresses,
uh,
the,
earthen bowl.
That outer ring is made of concrete concrete that we'll see is faced with opus
and Keratome work.
Uh,
and the entire structure is encircled by a,
an annular volt,
one of these ring volts that in circles,
the entire structure that is made out of concrete.
So another early example of the,
uh,
of the,
of the masterful use of concrete faced with opus and keratome work in this case,
in the amphitheater in Pompei,
I show you a Google earth image of this,
uh,
which gives you a very good sense of the oval shape of the original structure.
I think it's important to compare the exterior of amphitheater upon pay,
which is extremely well preserved as you can see here,
uh,
with the experiment at the much earlier a sanctuary of 14 for tuna premed Jania
at Palestrina where we also saw this use of concrete faced with opus and Keratin
work.
If we look at the facade of the amphitheater at Pompei,
we'll see first of all,
how exceedingly well preserved it was.
Uh,
we also see,
uh,
the,
this,
uh,
unique staircase here,
with,
uh,
stairs.
And I'll show you a side view in a moment where you can see those stairs,
stairs leading up on both sides.
Uh,
to the apex and then a series of arches in diminishing size,
larger in the center and diminishing in size as they go down the ramp to
correspond to the shape of the ramp.
Uh,
and then additional arcades over here,
these are what are called blind arcades because you'll see that they have wall a
wall in the back.
You can't walk in these arcades and get into the amphitheater.
There are only two barrel vaulted corridors and you saw them in the general view
on one on either long side of the oval,
uh,
that you can actually walk in and out of the,
of the amphitheater from them.
But you can go up the staircase and enter the amphitheater as well from the
Kavya go up to the top and then just go at the upper most top part of the steps
and walk down to your seats that way.
So the blind arcades,
we can see here,
we can see that once again,
just as we saw on some of the other buildings we looked at last time,
the way in which they've used opus and carried them for most of the wall,
the facing for the concrete for most of the wall.
But they have used stone,
uh,
both,
blocks of stone and these Bu's war blocks,
wedge shape blocks to uh,
articulate the arcades,
uh,
to make them more prominent and also to give the building,
additional,
uh,
stability.
What's interesting here and one of the reasons I also bring back the sanctuary
or Fortuna Prima Jania is the fact that the Romans,
again,
or giving you some options in terms of how you get into this building,
you can get in through the barrel vaulted carters,
uh,
or uh,
or,
or you can climb up this distinctive staircase.
And by the way,
we have no other,
this is truly is a unique staircase.
We have no other one like it in the history of Roman architecture.
So you have those options.
But again,
they are still predetermining the way in which you go.
I mean they give you a few options but uh,
within that scheme it is clearly a predetermined path.
Uh,
up the staircase over here and then through only those two barrel vaulted
Carter's and we talked about that at the Fortuna premed Jania sanctuary,
uh,
up the ramps and then up the staircase in the center.
A very similar way of thinking about getting people from one place to another in
an orderly way.
The staircase.
So distinctive that and here I show you a side view of it where you can actually
see the steps leading up.
And if you don't,
if you go visit there,
you should try both options.
I'm in go down the corridor.
But also it's a lot of fun to go up the steps and into the caveat.
Uh,
but it's so distinctive and,
and never to be repeated,
uh,
that when we look,
there's a painting that survives from a palm pay in house.
We'll look at it in more detail later in the semester,
but I wanted to just show it to you now because it is so apparent that it is a
representation of the amphitheater at palm pay,
which is not surprising since this is a house in palm pay.
But you see that distinctive staircase here with the steps,
uh,
the way in which you can enter into the copy or you get a sense of the coffee
and the kind of goings on that one that,
that happened in this Pompei amphitheater.
Uh,
but you can also see this is a very important detail that,
uh,
that is then this is the only place where we actually have a representation of
it.
You can see that at the upper most part of the caveat there is an awning called
the velarium and I've put that word on the monument lists for you and awning
that was supported by polls that were located on brackets at the upper most part
of the amphitheater.
And that awning,
the purpose of that owning the palm Payan seemed to have a thing for protecting
the Romans in general for protecting people in inclement weather.
Uh,
so they put these awnings up when it rained,
they put these awnings up to protect those who were there to see a gladiatorial
combat to protect them from that rain.
One last view of the amphitheater Pompei we are looking at it at its bowl shaped
arena as you can see here and the seats that do survive at to get a sense of the
interior here you can see very well the two a barrel vaulted entrances and exits
of one on either side and that's the only way.
Again,
those blind arcades you can't get in that way and you can see that very well
here.
Those are the only entrance or exits into the theater besides the staircase.
And in the introductory lecture I made the point and I'll just bring it back
home again,
that the Yale Bowl here in new haven is based on the amphitheater and palm pay.
There's no question about that.
In fact,
if one goes back in the literature on the bowl and its original construction,
it is even mentioned in original articles that the architects were looking back.
I mean,
I'm not making this up.
The architects were actually looking back at the palm pay amphitheater as a
model and you can see the relationship when you look at the bowl from the air,
you can see it as a bowl.
It's kind of a bowl shape almost exactly like the shape of the Pompei
amphitheater.
This aerial view by the way,
was taken at the time of the hundredth game between,
you know,
and Harvard and you can see the stands were packed.
Uh,
the major difference between these two amphitheaters,
uh,
is the fact that the one in palm pay was made to hold 20,000 people.
The one and Yale can hold up to as many as 78,000 people.
So we have a larger,
uh,
amphitheater,
so to speak here,
uh,
than they did and do in the theater in the city.
Pompei I want to move from the amphitheater to the other great entertainment
district of palm pay.
And that was the theater and the music hall,
the theater and the music hall.
And I want to show those two fairly quickly.
Uh,
we see them here in plan the theater in red and the music hall here in a kind
of,
I dunno,
chartreuse,
uh,
as you can see it dates to a 80 to 70 BC.
So another example of a building that was added when the Romans,
uh,
gained descendants of this part of the world.
Uh,
and uh,
a couple of terms,
again,
we can see if we look at the theater,
we can see the uh,
the fact that the theater is semi circular in shape or the copy is semi circular
and shape.
We can see the wedge shaped who ne up there.
Uh,
we can also see that the orchestra is semi circular in shape,
not round and that there's a scanner as CNA or a scan.
I frons is,
I called it last time a stage building at the front.
There is also a space over here which we call the porticas.
And again,
I put that on the monument list for you.
The portico is what was the port,
it goes to the port.
It as was an open rectangular space with covered colonnades on either side.
The purpose of the porticas was to have a place where people could go during
intermission,
uh,
to,
to stretch their legs during the intermission of the comedy or tragedy that they
were there to see.
A,
and there were little shops along the way,
a little spaces along the way.
Some of them served as shops for playbills and uh,
other souvenirs from the evenings experience.
Uh,
but also that served as spaces where props and scenery and costumes and all
sorts of things that were needed in the theatrical theatrical performances could
be kept.
So that's the port it goes.
Then over here we see the music hall.
It's a smaller version of the theater,
but it's designed in exactly the same way with a semicircular orchestral,
the semicircular copy of the division and to Kunae.
As you can see here,
a small inlet,
much less elaborate scanner in the front.
The major difference between the two and we see this not just in Palm Bay but
throughout Roman architecture is not just the scale that the theater is always
much bigger than the music hall,
but that the theater was open to the sky and the music hall was had a roof,
uh,
and that roof,
that roof,
the reason for the roof and the smaller music hall and the reason for the
smaller size was to be to make the acoustics as good as they could possibly be.
And that was easier to do in a roof building and an a building of smaller scale,
a Google earth view of the theater and music hall.
As they look today and you can see they're quite well preserved.
You can see the exact shapes that we looked at in plan over and over there.
Here's our porticas for example.
You get a sense of how pleasant that might be able to be during intermission
time.
Uh,
what this view also gives you a sense of however,
is the way in which these two buildings are embedded in the rest of the city
that they are.
They do make up an entertainment district,
but at the same time,
they are very close to the city streets that have,
uh,
on along them houses and shops and so on and so forth.
So very closely embedded into the life,
into the commercial life and the residential life of the city.
Even though this was intended,
again,
as a great entertainment area for those who live there.
And I made this point before,
but I'll make it quickly again,
that while Roman theaters like the theater Pompei are based on Greek prototypes.
There are some differences.
Uh,
they,
the two theaters,
this is the Greek theater at Epidaurus of the mid fourth century BC.
They both have the stone seats.
They both have,
which is called the Kavya.
They both have these wedge shapes,
sections of seats.
They both have a stage building,
although the Greek one is much simpler.
Uh,
and uh,
they all,
but the major differences between the two is that the Greek theater has a
circular or Kestra,
whereas the Roman theater,
it has a,
and this is the theater of Pompei has a semicircular orchestra.
And the other major difference,
the most significant one is the Greeks built their theaters on hillsides.
As you can see it up adores the Romans,
built their theaters.
And this is the case in palm pay on a hill made out of concrete.
I want to turn to an extremely important building and one that I am going to,
uh,
come back to on a number of occasions during the semester.
So put an asterisk next to this one as a particularly important building in one
that it's almost certain I'll find some way of incorporating into the mid term,
mid term,
uh,
because I think it's so significant and it will,
it will turn up again and again and again in the course of the term,
especially when we talk about later bath architecture.
It is a stogie and bas of Pompei.
It dates to the second half of the second century BC and it was remodeled in the
first half of the first century BC.
This dobby and bas are one of several bath buildings at palm pay.
I mentioned in the introductory lecture that uh,
the,
these houses in palm pay did not have running water.
And so access to bathing and to water for daily use was obviously critical and
the bath serve that purpose,
the place where one could go and bathe,
but they were also,
they also became great social centers,
great places where you really wanted to go and hang out with your friends while
you were sitting in the sauna.
And uh,
and so they take on a very,
they are a very important piece of life in cities like palm pay,
the stobby and Baz is there date indicate or very early there begun already
under the Sam Nights.
And they have some extremely interesting features.
And once again,
I'm going to have to go over some of the bath terminology.
You can see here that if you walk along street,
you just see a series of cubicles which served the shop.
So,
you know,
fairly unprepossessing,
uh,
but there is an entrance way through those shops into a very large open space
surrounded by columns on three sides that is called the [inaudible] of the
baths.
The polestar was the exercise courts where you jogged and,
and uh,
you know,
and ran around and so on.
And after you exerted yourself and got all sweaty,
you could jump into the pool that was located over here.
This was not a place to do laps.
It was pretty much a soaking pool or pool where you can cool off.
Uh,
but the technical term for that is either a PC now,
which is what's on the monument list for you,
or a natal ito and a t eight t I o a little pool where you could splash yourself
after exerting yourself by exercising in the Polestar,
the build up the bath block itself,
the bathing rooms themselves are located on the other side of the plan on the
right side as you see it here,
the northern side actually of the plan.
Uh,
and we see two sets of spaces.
This set of four down here,
this one,
this one and this one.
And then a set of a comparable number of rooms up there,
these early Roman baths.
There was a separation between the men section of the Bas and the women's
section of the Bas.
And I'm sorry ladies,
but um,
we'll have to accept the fact that at least an ancient Pompei,
uh,
the women's section was quite nondescript.
It was much smaller than the men's.
At least they had one thank goodness.
Uh,
but it was smaller than the men's and the rooms had no architectural distinction
whatsoever.
All of the designers effort went into creating,
uh,
a wonderful set of room for the men.
And we see the men's rooms again over here,
these four and the women's at the top.
Consequently,
the only ones that have any merit architecturally in my share showing you today
are the ones for the men's baths down here.
Uh,
the four rooms,
the four key rooms to both the men's and women's sections were the Apo d
Terrian.
And again,
these words that are on the monument list for you,
the [inaudible],
which was the dressing room.
It's a fairly,
again,
it's large,
but a fairly nondescript rectangular room here.
You can see it right down here.
And the way it was designed was that you went in and there were no lockers,
no private lockers,
but uh,
there were benches where you could,
when you got undressed,
you could just take your clothes and put them in a little pile on that bench.
Uh,
you have to just take on faith that no one was going to steal any of your
belongings.
And if you were very well to do some of the very well to do Romans,
men and women brought slaves with them,
their slave,
their private slave to watch their stuff while they were in the sauna with their
friends from the auditorium.
You go into the so called a Doriam of the Baz.
Also usually a plain rectangular room,
even in the men's section,
which served as the warm room,
where you started to warm yourself up.
You went from the tip of Doriam into the call Darian of the bath,
which was the a hot room,
uh,
the where you really,
where it was,
the sauna essentially of the bath.
And consequently there was a,
um,
a basin over here with cold waters.
If you've got too hot,
you could go and splash yourself,
uh,
with that cold water.
So Apple d tarian tepid,
Darian called Rem.
By then you're really heated up and you can make your way back into this room
over here,
which is called the [inaudible] or the cold room.
The frigate.
Darian was a place that you could really cool off.
And I think you can see by looking at these,
the two most important rooms,
architecturally,
you can see this even in plan are the caldarium,
which has an apps are curved element at the end.
Uh,
and this room in particular,
the frigate Darian,
uh,
because it is a round structure with radiating alcoves and we're going to see
that it's domed.
This is a particularly again,
Star Star Star Star,
one of the most important rooms that I've shown you,
probably the most important room I've shown you thus far this semester in that
it is going to have a very long future.
Architecturally what you see here basically ends up as the Pantheon a someday,
uh,
this round space round structure with radiating alcoves and as we'll see a dome
and not only a dome but a hole in the ceiling and Oculus,
it allows light into the structure.
Uh,
how were these baths a heated?
How were the hot rooms he did through a system called a hypo cost.
Again,
I put them on the word on the monument list for you.
A hypo cost,
h.
Y p.
What was a hypo cost system?
A hypo cost system was a system by which they put terracotta
terracotta,
um,
tubes in the floor and behind the walls they blew hot air into those and they
also raised up the pavement of the floor on a series of stacked tiles.
And you can see that extremely well was a very well preserved hypo costs from
the stop being Baz place these tiles on stack stacks of tiles let leaving space
in between them and put Braziers,
uh,
between those tin,
tin,
metal,
Braziers,
uh,
metal bowls that held hot coals and so on.
And that from those hot coals,
obviously it's slaves who had to,
you know,
keep those,
slept,
those coals hot,
but calls that were placed in these pans that,
uh,
that,
helped also to heat the pavement that was located above the,
this very important room,
the [inaudible] of the stubby and Baz,
you see it here as it looks today,
a small round space.
Uh,
it has a,
it would,
it would have had a pool in the center around pool radiating alcoves,
uh,
a dome,
a dome that is open to the sky with an Oculus and allows light into it.
You can see the remains of paint stucco and then paint blue and red paint.
Probably some kind of marine seen,
uh,
included here.
But this,
I can't underscore enough the importance of this particular room and the future
that this design has for Roman architecture.
I'd like to show you,
um,
another bath at Pompei,
the so called foreign bows.
The Forum bounds are interesting because they're later.
They date two,
as you can see from your monument list of ADBC.
So this is what the Romans did when they came in and took over palm pay and
we're making it into one of those mini Rome's those cities and the in the,
in the,
um,
and the model of Rome.
And you can see it as very,
very similar to what was going on in the Stogie and bows and the earlier Sam
night baths,
uh,
with the same polestar we see a polestar up at to the exercise court.
We don't seem to have a Natacha.
And this particular plan,
uh,
we see the men's section over here at three,
four,
five and six and the women's section over here,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10.
Again,
the women's section off to the side of,
no,
our architectural distinction whatsoever.
Uh,
the men's over here and you can enter the men's either through the Polestar or
permit opening over here at one,
we see the same set of rooms that we saw at the stop and baths.
We see the [inaudible] or dressing,
undressing and dressing room over here at three,
the tepid Arrium at five.
The caldarium at six in the caldarium at six is of the same shape as the
caldarium and the stobby and Baz,
a rectangular room with an apse at the end and a um,
a basin for cold water splashes.
And then you go back again to the frigate Dorian and you can see the frigging
Darian in the bads,
a forum baths upon pay,
the same shape as that in the stobby and Basit Pompei,
a round,
a small round room with radiating alcoves.
I can show you views both of the [inaudible] of the forum,
Baz extremely well preserved.
As you can see here,
you can also see they've used a great barrel vault for this room.
It isn't as large as it looks here,
but it's a sizable room and this is a very good place to show you by the way,
to give you a sentence of how these things were decorated,
how so many rooms to Roman rooms today.
Roman buildings today are stripped of their original decoration.
Uh,
but that decoration was often quite beautiful and ostentatious.
And we can see here a,
we can get here a sense of that.
You can see the wall has been stuccoed over.
And then also in Stucco,
these great flowering of campus plants and uh,
creatures flying above animals,
human feature of Gods and goddesses flying above paint was up.
You know,
you,
they use paint as well,
red and blue and white and other colors,
uh,
to accentuate the design.
This could you some sense of the flavor of these and then this wonderful detail
below of these atlas figures who are shown holding up the vault of this
particular room.
It gives you some sense of why Romans flocked to these places,
not only because it was the only place they can bathe themselves,
but also because it was just a wonderful space to be in and to enjoy.
Again,
the company of friends.
This is a view of what room
and the forum baths,
the caldarium excellent Neil,
the caldarium,
uh,
over here with it's a rectangular shape and then it's apps and it's cold water,
Bay basin for cold water splashes.
And then look at the ceiling.
How wonderful in that,
in that,
uh,
apps,
you see a semi dome,
a,
a round hole or an oculus in that semi dome to allow light into it.
So here we see them exploring occupy in semi domes as well as in domes.
And then the square and rectangular,
uh,
spaces,
holes in the ceiling,
uh,
openings in the ceiling that had been placed there also to allow light into the
system so that you could use the room,
but also to create the kind of wonderful light effects that it does when you
have rays of sunshine coming in on you while you are in your sauna.
This is a couple of more views.
This is a couple of views of the frigging Doriam of the forum baths.
You can see the dome up above the Oculus in that dome.
You can see some of the stucco decorations still preserved.
You can see the alcoves here,
the radiating alcoves and some of the stucco decoration.
He or sea creatures against a red background.
And this is a restored view of what the Frig Darian would've looked like with
the pool in the center and nice place to relax.
The radiating,
uh,
apps is over here.
And then the dome with the Oculus and with the light streaming in.
Again,
I can't underscore enough the importance of both of these for Galleria,
uh,
for the future of Roman architecture.
Uh,
the other importance of the Foreign Baz is the forum.
Baz is today where you can eat and if you're there for the full day as I
recommend you be,
you're going to want to eat at some point.
Uh,
and there is a cafeteria which doesn't look like much,
but actually the food is not bad though.
Italians have a very hard time making bad pasta so you can always get some good
pasta at the snack bar and you will don't want to make your way.
There's a few views of it make your way to the forum.
Baz,
if you're there for any length of time,
very quickly,
I just want to remind you,
we talked about this in the introductory lecture that one of the main reasons
that Pompei so interesting to us today is because it tells us so much about the
daily life,
not only of the palm pans,
but if the Romans in general,
because we have all these wonderful shops still preserved at palm pay.
This was a bakery.
We see the millstones that were actually used for the grinding of the grains
still preserved.
We see the oven over here looking wonderfully like a modern pizza oven.
As you can see.
And we also believe it or not have from Pompei a petrified bread that's still is
preserved.
Uh,
that gives you a sense of what Pompei and bread looked like.
And it looks,
it looks strikingly like our pizzas with the segments,
segments of the breads.
So if you want to have a sense of where pizza came from here,
I told you the Romans,
again,
there's nothing the Romans didn't invent bread,
pizza,
whatever.
Uh,
but you see that,
that divide,
Brad giving you a very good sense of the,
of the,
of what was produced in this particular bakery.
I also mentioned in the introductory lecture,
the fast food stands of Pompei,
the Thermop oleum in the singular and the thermal polio in the plural.
These fast food stands where you could get a bite real,
real quickly.
The way they were designed was to have a great counter in them with recesses,
uh,
fresh,
hot and cold food was put out obviously every day.
Uh,
and if you are hungry,
you just went up to the counter.
You took a peek at what was there,
you pointed out what you wanted and you could eat on the run.
Uh,
the Romans were never far to have,
you know,
their state religion and their family religion far from them.
Uh,
and you can also see a nod to the gods over here.
There's a shrine,
a with some of the representations of the household gods.
Even in this fast food emporium,
we have wine shops from palm pay as well.
I show you actually a scene of one of the storage rooms had Pompei I that you
can see actually as you walk along.
So wonderful ruffling of turning to the next page.
Uh,
the,
um,
these wine,
these average,
these great clay amphoras,
that held line,
uh,
that are located in one of these storage areas that one can see is one walks
along the forum on the left side in palm pay today.
But you can imagine these on shelves,
uh,
in a wine shop of ancient Pompei,
offering wines are gathered from all over the world,
uh,
for discerning,
files.
Is that the word?
Oenophiles uh,
connecting all of these,
um,
shops to one another.
We're of course the streets of the city,
the streets of the city are extremely well preserved.
I show you here a couple of views of the crossing of the carto and the deck.
Your Montas in palm pay a and you can see exactly what the streets look like.
You can see the,
uh,
multi-sided paving stones of the streets.
You can see the sidewalks looking uncannily modern.
Uh,
you can see,
I don't,
you can't see exactly here,
but their drains along the way to allow rain water to filter off the streets.
Uh,
and all of this,
again,
an extremely modern look and the streets of Pompei give us the best sense of any
of any streets of any preserved ancient city of what a,
what the streets look like in any given Roman town.
These streets had a long them again because of needs for water,
had a long fountains.
He was a very modest fountain where we see a representation of the goddess
series,
a cers series with her Cornucopia and the fountain spout coming out of her
mouth.
Uh,
and uh,
you can see this is the sort of thing when the Romans just needed a little bit
of water for household use,
they would go out to the local fountain.
So as you walk along the streets upon pay,
you see a lot of these small fountains.
You also see graffiti.
What would a city be without some graffiti on its buildings?
Any of you have been in Rome recently?
No,
there is too much graffiti.
There's like a graffiti,
uh,
craze.
I mean the Romans have always had a lot of graffiti but it's gotten so bad it's,
it's almost unimaginable now.
But the graffiti tradition was alive and well in palm pay a and you see it here
covered with glass,
but you see it here.
You see it here and there and the city as you wander by.
And it gives you a sense that people did right,
right on their buildings.
These,
what they wrote on these buildings tended to be political for the most part.
You know,
you'd see graffiti that would say things like a vote for vote for Barbata us,
the bearded one.
Uh,
he's will be the best guy for the office.
And he's pretty handsome too.
That's the kind of graffiti that you'll see as you walk along.
If you're Latin has good that you'll see as you walk along the streets of palm
pay,
you'll also see these big blocks of stone.
And there are people who look at these and they think,
oh,
how impressing that's debris from Vesuvius.
It's not debris from Vesuvius.
Clearly these are,
they are deliberately,
these are stepping stones.
The Romans were so ingenious and so again,
concerned about how to protect people in inclement weather,
uh,
that they created.
They put these stepping stones all around the city,
usually at the cross sections of two streets,
so that if there was torrential rain and if the water piled up and if the drains
couldn't quite handle it,
uh,
you could get across the street,
without stepping in the water.
And we had this and the slushing this,
that was new haven in the last week.
I can't tell you how many times I think,
why doesn't yell have stepping stones?
Uh,
we really could use them,
but here they are.
And you can see very clearly the ruts that come from the carts that have been,
that were made between the stepping stones by those carts constantly riding
through them.
And it shows you that they had to orchestrate the wheels of the carts in such a
way that they would span,
uh,
the stepping stones.
But it's a very ingenious thing.
They're fun to look at,
a fun to walk on,
Fun,
really fun to take pictures.
I have tons of them.
I didn't decided not to bring a personal picture this time,
me or anyone else in my family on stepping stones or other Yalies.
I've got lots of those too.
I didn't bring those today,
but I did bring something I'm really proud of because in all the years I've
taught this monument,
this city,
excuse me,
I've always wanted to actually show what it looked like when rain,
uh,
when w when it had rained and since I've been to palm pay so,
so many times over the years.
Uh,
but it doesn't tend to rain when I go there.
You know,
June,
July,
August,
it doesn't rain.
So I've never been able to do that.
I was there this past June,
and Lo and behold,
I was very upset because who wants to wander around the city of palm pay in the
rain?
But I had one day to go there and I was there and I said,
wow,
it's raining.
He was my chance.
So I finally was able to get some views of what happens.
And this was right at,
we had a torrential rain for about a half an hour.
Then the sun came out.
And this is what you see as you wander the streets.
You see that the water has accumulated.
But again,
Lo and behold,
you can easily make your way across that street,
across those stepping stones.
Uh,
nonetheless,
just a very few words on what happens to the streets of the city of palm or any
Roman city for that matter.
When you leave the gates and you go out on the Inter city roads,
many of those intercity roads become cemeteries.
The Romans used these roads as their cemeteries.
The Romans had,
uh,
a,
a religious belief that you,
that there was a separation between the city of the living and the city of the
dead.
So all of the tombs are outside the walls of the city.
Uh,
so you see at palm pay to extremely WellPreserved tomb streets,
the treat and the street of the tombs and the BIA new Chera,
which is the one you see here and new cra with tombs of all sorts of shapes and
sizes.
I'm not going to go into these in any detail in this course.
There is a paper topic for any of you who get interested in to market texture on
the tombs of Pompei.
We will look at some tombs and Rome in great detail,
but I'm just going to give you a glimpse of them here.
They come in all sizes and shapes.
They're very,
very interesting.
They honor the people who were buried there,
including there's an a bench to him for example,
where you can sit and think on the,
uh,
the life and times of,
of the individual who was buried there.
Uh,
so an absolutely fascinating,
fascinating.
A street with a lot of different tumor types that show the variety of two
marketecture under the Romans.
I'd like to end today,
I'd like to end today by by making at least a passing reference to a matter
which is of huge concern to archeologists and huge concern to all of us as human
beings.
And that is what happened to the people upon pay in those very last moments of
life.
And archeologists have been able to reconstruct exactly what happened to,
uh,
or not exactly,
but as close as possible in this day,
you know,
in,
in the time from which Pompei was excavated to now to reconstruct again what
happened to these,
these human beings at the time of the eruption of the [inaudible],
they've been able to,
again,
to reconstruct a very moving picture of their last moments of life.
What we know is that the,
uh,
ash and lava from Vesuvius and you see a,
a restored view here of what that would have been,
would have looked like.
And you can see,
but vs,
and you can see the forum over here with the Temple of Jupiter and the temple of
Apollo and the throngs of people inside the forum at this particular juncture is
they look up and see what is happening.
And on the right hand side,
this is actually a view of Mount Saint Helen's,
which is,
you know,
erupted in 1980 and the eruptions not so different as you can as you gaze upon
them and look at them in comparison today.
But we know that the,
that the eruption of the Suviet [inaudible] did not happen all at once.
It didn't just happen and covered the city.
It was gradual.
There was actually quite a bit of time.
There was time to escape the Ra,
the Pompey and saw what was happening.
And those who were smart did escape.
But like any other natural disaster,
there were of course,
a group of hardy souls,
or perhaps we would call them foolhardy souls who thought that they could ride
it out and they thought they could ride it out by hiding in their own houses or
buy some of the smarter ones that the foolhardy type,
uh,
decided that they could ride it out in some of the very strong walled buildings,
public buildings of the city.
For example,
the bath buildings,
the stobby and bounds of the foreign bats that we looked at today,
they were gravely mistaken,
gravely mistaken.
We don't know how many stayed.
We think it was actually a fairly small number.
Some have said about a thousand.
We don't know.
Uh,
but whatever,
those who did stay had made a grave error because they were not actually killed
by the ash and lava,
the multinational lava,
despite the fact that it was extremely hot.
But what killed them was the noxious gases that came into the city after the
eruption that followed that ash and lava.
They were,
it's fixated by those gases before you,
after they had died,
but before their bodies decomposed.
The ash and lava formed a protective shell around their bodies,
uh,
protecting them.
And what the archeologists were clever enough to do is when the modern
archaeologists,
when they're working with their pickaxes and when that pickax hit a hollow in
the,
uh,
in the ash and lava,
they poured plaster into that hollow sometimes that produce nothing,
but sometimes it produced bodies,
the actual shape of the bodies of those whose bodies had decomposed there.
And we can look at those bodies still today.
And I show you a scene of a number of the victims of Pompei huddled together for
mutual and indeed,
ultimately futile protection.
I can show you the body of an individual who is lying on the ground,
his face in his hands,
trying to protect himself,
obviously from those noxious gases that have come into the city.
I can show you the,
uh,
the body of the plaster cast obviously of the body of another Pompei and who was
sitting with his knees up and his hands in front of his face trying to protect
himself once again from those fumes that are about to overtake him any second.
The body of an individual who's essentially given up at this point.
He is expired,
he's lying on his back.
There is no hope any longer for him.
Uh,
a poor fellow who died on that day.
And then this,
this fellow,
this heroic fellow who is lifting himself and his last moment of life lifting
himself either to gasp,
last breath or perhaps to whisper something to an endeared to a dear family
member who is by his side.
And we even have,
uh,
the body of a dog.
This story is particularly sad because this dog,
this plaster cast of this dog was found with a chain around his neck.
So probably what happened here is the owner of this particular dog had the dog
chained up,
didn't have time either to take the dog or to release the dog from his chains so
that he could try himself to escape.
And that poor dog perished on that day.
And we have the plaster cast of his body still today.
All of these bodies can still be seen on the site of Pompei and make a visit.
They're all the more poignant I know of,
no more moving human document from the ancient world.
Then these bodies of these Pompei Ans,
uh,
kept in perpetuity and for us to commiserate with and to understand even today.
Thank you.